اخبار جديده اليوم نسمعها عن لاعب كره
القدم داني الفيش المتهم بقضيه اغتصاب
فتاه في ملهى ليلي في برشلونه والذي وضع
في السجن رهن الاحتجاز من 20 يناير ورفض
القاضي الافراج عنه بكفاله اكثر من مره
الى حين الحكم المحكمه وللتذكير وضع داني
في القضيه ليس جيدا خاصه بعد ان غير
اقواله اربع مرات وتخلى نادي عنه وفسخ
تعاقده معه اما زوجته فبعد ان اعلنت دعمها
له بدايه عادت وطلبت الطلاق منه يبدو بعد
تاكدها من تورطه في القضيه الجديد اليوم
هو انباء عن دخول دانه الفيش في اضراب عن
الطعام حزنا على طلب زوجته بالطلاق
المعلومات تقول ان اللاعب متوتر وعصبي
وحزين ويرفض الطعام منذ زياره زوجته
الاخيره له في فبراير واخبارها له وجها
لوجه بنيتها انهاء الزواج
هي عارضه ازياء وزوجه داني وكانت كما قلنا
سندته بدايه لكنها عادت سريعا وطلبت الطلق
ومن ايام نشرت بوست على حسابها على
انستغرام قالت ان الاشهر الماضيه كانت
مروعه جدا ومن اصعب ايام حياتها وان داني
الفيش كان شريكا مثاليا وانها لا تصدق ان
شخصا احبته بكل صدق قادر على تحطيمها بهذا
الشكل وان الامس يستغرق سنوات حتى تنسى ما
حصل جوان قالت انها انسانه مستقله وذكيه
ومراعيه ومخلصه ولانها كل ذلك فستبقى
بجانب دانيال وانما بصوره مختلفه وانهت
حديثها بانها الان تختتم مرحله من حياتها
بدات في مايو 2018 وهو تاريخ زواجها من
داني وانها امراه تتحضر للانتقال من مرحله
لاخرى من حياتها